and
coming back to the bigger question about
that you worried about that
that there will be unintentional
failures i think
there are two quite separate risks here
right we talked a lot about one of them
which is that
the goals are noble of the human the
human says i want this
airplane to not crash because this is
not muhammad atta now flying the
airplane right
and now there's this technical challenge
of making sure that the
the autopilot is actually going to
behave as as the pilot wants
if you set that aside there's also the
separate question how do you make sure
that the goals of the pilot are actually
aligned with the goals of the passenger
how do you
make sure very much more broadly that if
we can all agree as a species that we
would like things to kind of go well for
humanity as a whole
that the goals are aligned here the
alignment problem
and um yeah there's been a lot of
progress in in the sense that there's
suddenly
huge amounts of research going on on it
about it i'm i'm very grateful to elon
musk for giving us that money five years
ago so we could launch the first
research program on
technical ai safety and alignment
there's a lot of stuff happening
but i think we need to do more than just
make sure little machines do always what
their owners do
you know that wouldn't have prevented
september 11. if muhammad after said
okay okay autopilot please fly into
world trade center you know and it's
like okay
that even happened in a different
situation there was this depressed
pilot named andreas lubitz right he told
his german wings passenger jet to fly
into the alps
he just told the computer to change the
altitude 200 meters or something like
that and you know what the computer said
all right okay okay and it had the
freaking topographical map of the alps
in there it had gps
everything no one had bothered teaching
it even the basic kindergarten ethics of
like no we never want airplanes to fly
into
mountains under any circumstances
and so we have to think beyond just
the the technical
issues and think about how do we align
in general incentives on this planet
for the greater good so starting with
simple stuff like that
every airplane that has a computer in it
should be taught
whatever kindergarten ethics that's
smart enough to understand like
no don't fly into fixed objects if the
pilot tells you to do so
then go on autopilot mode
send an email to the cops and land at
the latest airport
nearest airport you know any car
with a forward-facing camera should just
be programmed by the
by the manufacturer so it will never
accelerate into a human ever
that would have avoid things like the
nice
attack and many horrible terrorist
vehicle attacks where they deliberately
did that right
this was not some sort of thing oh you
know us and china
different views on no there was not a
single car manufacturer in the world
in the world right who wanted the cars
to do this they just hadn't thought to
do the alignment and if you look at
more broadly problems that happen on
this planet
the vast majority have to do a poor
alignment
you